[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a francia que conmemora 80 años de
la detención de miles de judíos de
origen extranjero que vivían en parís un
pequeño jardín de piedra junto a un
edificio de oficinas eso es todo lo que
queda en la ciudad del velódromo de
invierno un gran polideportivo
construido a principios del siglo 20 hoy
destruido pero cuyo nombre ha
permanecido asociado a una huella
imborrable en la historia de francia la
redada del velódromo de invierno el 16 y
17 de julio de 1942 más de 13.000 judíos
fueron detenidos en parís y su región
por la policía
la orden era no separar a las familias
por lo que se llevaron a más de 4.000
niños junto con sus padres durante cinco
días estuvieron encerrados en ese lugar
casi sin agua y sin comida para luego
ser llevados a otros centros de
internamiento en francia donde las
familias fueron separadas antes de
abordar un tren al campo de exterminio
de auschwitz de las 13.000 personas
arrestadas en la redada sólo 100
regresaron en 1995 el presidente de
entonces jacques chirac reconoció por
primera vez
usabilidad del estado francés en la
persecución y deportación de judíos
durante la ocupación nuestro reporteros
se reunieron con los últimos testigos de
la redada del velódromo de indiana
me llevo los
dos
[Música]
jane screen fútbol y soy nixon
de las
12 m
de su infancia rachel jedinak conservo
el yiddish
una infancia en parís en una familia de
inmigrantes judíos polacos
y éramos felices porque éramos amados
por nuestros padres que querían vernos
crecer como verdaderos pequeños
franceses
pero el mayo de 1941 la vida en familia
da un vuelco el padre de rachel fue
detenido durante la redada del boleto
verde junto con 3700 hombres judíos
extranjeros
un año más tarde a principios del verano
de 1942 algunos rumores anuncian una
nueva redada
esta vez concierne a las mujeres y a los
niños
la madre de rachel les entrega a sus dos
hijas a sus abuelos
llegué el 16 de julio de 1942
estábamos aquí en la madrugada empezaron
los golpes en la puerta de mis abuelos
policía abra
paul y sube
la abuela de rachel duda pero obedece
los policías franceses la encaran
les ordenará a los niños que se preparen
para unirse a su madre las dos niñas
regresan a su casa el reencuentro fue
desgarrador
a la familia la conducen escoltada por
las calles de la localidad 20
[Música]
lo vi por las ventanas
gente agrupada nos veía pasar como
manada
algunos hacían la señal de cruz con
lágrimas en los ojos
otros nos señalaban riendo a las madres
gritaban pero a dónde vamos a dónde nos
lleva
y los policías no respondían en el
planeta
rachel su hermana y su madre fueron
reunidas con los otros judíos del barrio
en los locales de del hilo a un lugar
social y cultural de ménil monzó
la madre entendió que lo peor estaba por
venir es ordenó a sus hijas que huyeran
por la salida de emergencia
hice un show increíble
no quiero dejar de gritarle
y me dio una cachetada violenta la única
cachetada de mi vida más tarde entendí
que esa cachetada me salvó la vida
algunos policías miran para otro lado
rachel y su hermana logra salir acaban
de escapar de nuevo de la redada del
velódromo de indiana
nos encontramos frente al salón de vélez
billones que es uno de los cuatro
centros de agrupación de la localidad 20
la gente es clasificada antes de enviar
a los adultos sin hijos a transit
es decir al velódromo de invierno donde
las familias han sido ubicadas
el origen de esta redada fue una
solicitud de los alemanes que exigían
que se les entregaran judíos en edad de
trabajar el gobierno de vichy dirigido
por pierre la vag acepta pero con la
condición de elegirlos y que la policía
francesa sea autónoma
el acuerdo establecido por el jefe de la
policía de beach y rené busquets en
nombre de pierre laval consiste en
entregar 30.000 jodidos en la zona
ocupada la mayoría está en parís en 1940
150.000 judíos fueron censadas en parís
es en donde había que entregar a la
mayoría de judíos
el 16 y el 17 de julio de 1942 otros mil
policías parisinos fueron movilizados
detuvieron a 12 mil 884 judíos en la
capital y su periferia entre ellos a la
familia de rougier de origen polaco que
vivía en la localidad 10 el padre era un
antiguo combatiente que se enlistó en
1939 a favor de francia su hija anne
tenía 10 años en ese entonces en la
mañana del 16 de julio comienzan los
golpes en la puerta
la madre trata de interponerse frente a
la policía
ella dijo nuestra hija nació en francia
es una francesa no puede deportar
en ese momento dijo
nos separamos de los hijos de las
familias tenemos corazón
y es conducida con sus padres en bus
hacia la calle gelato en la localidad 15
donde se encuentra el velódromo de
invierno el lugar elegido para reunir a
los judíos detenidos
[Música]
que la gente hacía fila sin decir nada
como animales en el matadero
el japonés
y mi padre estaba muerto antes de
estarlo realmente
no se imaginaba que francia le engañaría
no era posible
no entendió
mientras que su esposo acepta su suerte
la madre de año lo intenta todo habla
con los policías diciendo que su hija
debe calmarse nada más se encuentran en
un momento dado en un pasillo de
edificios
necesitas molar que le llama monte fuji
apremiaba agassi
fue en ese momento que tuvo un instante
de locura
tras arrancar mi estrella que se
sostenía con un hilo arranco la suya
pasamos entre la gente que esperaba
les pregunto a los gendarmes puedo pasar
señor y nos dejaron pasar
[Música]
en el pasto
ra la común así fuimos del velódromo en
invierno
el padre de año entró en esta sala de
deportes el velódromo de invierno más de
8000 personas fueron detenidas durante
varios días más de la mitad eran niños
era un horror era la primera vez que
mujeres y niños eran detenidos
masivamente mujeres embarazadas adultos
mayores cuando las familias vivían
juntas todas eran detenidos y enviados
al velódromo de invierno
en antiguo estadio ya no existe un
jardín en memoria de los niños del
velódromo de invierno fue inaugurado
las caras de las pequeñas víctimas y sus
apellidos han sido expuestos
este episodio sombrío de la historia de
francia
sólo existe una foto conocida
en esta foto un policía vigila en el
andén de enfrente están los buses y los
diferentes modelos de buses que fueron
usados para conducir personas detenidas
desde las localidades parisinas hasta el
velódromo de invierno en el andén
podemos ver algunas personas con maletas
ya no queda nada del velódromo de
invierno hoy en día entonces esta foto
es importante para la memoria
a sus 4 años
berna news pan hizo parte de esos
internados con su madre ida fue detenido
en la localidad 11 en la mañana del 16
de julio eran tan sólo dos en su
domicilio el padre ya había sido
detenido un año antes durante la redada
del boleto verde unas horas más tarde y
aznar vida descubren el horror del
velódromo de invierno
y son como sea
y la gente empezó a gritar
no valía la pena ir a los baños era
demente la gente orina o en el muro
y
el recuerdo que me marcó es de una mujer
se tiró desde la barandilla en lo alto
de verdad se suicidó suicide
[Música]
era insoportable
la madre de bagdad decide escaparse pero
los policías tapan las salidas aprovecha
un cambio de turno y logra salir hacia
la calle en el ato
el ineficiente pero
en ese momento un policía dice que hacen
aquí no es un lugar
están estorbando váyase se fue pero era
dónde
y aznar y su madre encuentran refugio en
un café frente al velódromo de invierno
entonces una mesera les ofrece comida un
policía les propone a ayudarlos
se dirigió sea mi madre virtual le quitó
la estrella y le dijo no se mueva
quédese aquí hasta las 16 horas a las 16
horas se termina la redada
y efectivo acceso
se va de parís uno de los policías nos
acompañó hasta el metro fue increíble
nos acompañó hasta el metro
berna y su madre se salvaron de lo peor
a diferencia de las otras familias
reunidas en el velódromo de invierno no
fueron conducidos unos días más tarde a
lo que es aquí a un centenar de
kilómetros al sur de parís estos judíos
parisinos son internados en dos campos
en pithiviers ibón lago lando bajo la
supervisión de los gendarmes franceses
promiscuidad falta de higiene agua y
alimentos las condiciones eran
agotadoras pero al cabo de algunos días
el horror alcanzó un grado adicional las
familias fueron separadas
los alemanes aún no reclamaban a los
niños los adultos son despachados y los
niños porque hay un imperativo
ferroviario los trenes debían salir
entonces había que hacer salir los que
podían por ahora la violencia para
separar a las familias fue terrorífica
para desmembrar las
los niños fueron abandonados frente a
los gendarmes algunos asistentes
sociales
un muro de retratos les rinde homenaje
en sears y el memorial de los niños del
velódromo de invierno en orleans
atención recuerdo su terrible destino
para este museo
todos han sucumbido el ritmo algunos se
volvieron locos son sufrieron de hecho
ya no existen hay que ocuparse de ellos
porque ya no están en alguna medida se
fueron con sus padres
durante las semanas siguientes tal como
sus padres los niños también fueron
deportados al campo de exterminación de
louisville que no los 4000 niños del
velódromo de invierno tan sólo seis
regresaron vivos
para no olvidarlos rachel jedinak se
impuso una misión
hacer inscribir sus nombres en los muros
de las escuelas parisinas
[Música]
en este vital de un líder era vital
hacer reunió sus apellidos en sus
escuelas porque no tenemos cementerios
estos niños que habían reído cantado
llorado crecido había que darles vida de
nuevo en su escuela
y w
desde 1997
450 placas han sido ubicadas en fachadas
y al interior de los establecimientos
escolares
y estas dos placas me generan muchas
emociones porque están mis primas el
primo y todos estos niños
me siento un poco tranquila porque su
nombre está en su escuela y está bien
es la prueba de que existieron
[Música]
viaja nos va también logró sacar fuerza
de su infancia y robada es una carrera
en el sector de la confección se metió
en política fue elegido en jacques en la
región de parís
[Música]
con all in one with your
no hay ninguna duda
en vez de una estrella judía tenía una
un fannba azul blanco rojo
es lo que se llama una venganza
aquí onda una defensa
me vengué nunca lo hice pensando pero me
vengué
el día que fui elegido me dije no es
posible que un pequeño judío yo al que
le hicieron sufrir hoy en día
era para llorar se da cuenta quién
habría pensado un instante que un día yo
sería alcalde adjunto de la república
francesa eso no se explica
dangerous o se volvió médico también
contrajo matrimonio tuvo tres hijos ocho
nietos y seis bisnietos
[Música]
cuando nos reunimos cuento sobrevivir y
el generado 30 g
[Música]
una felicidad que resume en yidish la
lengua de su infancia
[Música]
y
yo le digo estas palabras que quieren
decir la alegría que dan los años es eso
y
[Música]
porque quieren
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta que nos llevó a conocer
la redada del velódromo de invierno de
en francia recuerde que si quiere ver
este y otros episodios en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto